we hope to miss them I found in Dobby
isn't shared by everyone though
particularly because rolls-royce they're
cutting jobs in the area I sat down with
the MP for dubbing South Dame Margaret
Beckett the former Foreign Secretary and
one of the longest-serving MPs in
Parliament and I started by asking her
how resilient the economy is in Darby I
think in general terms the economy
should be very resilient because we have
this high-quality high-grade
manufacturing with companies that are
competitive across the world but of
course the difficulty that we have now
is that bread as it could potentially be
putting a lot of that at risk
I mean rolls-royce for example as you
may know has decided to start licensing
their big engines at their plant in
Germany and that is now a permanent move
now that's a smallish thing but it's not
a comfortable one because there's a lot
of stuff that they could move to Germany
or elsewhere in the world if they felt
they should at the same time there has
been some recent move investment in D
Derby so you've had Toyota for example
just started to build their corona model
there
JCB where we went to you and saying that
they have created 50 new jobs I mean
this doesn't seem the actions of
companies to worried about bracelet.i
I shouldn't I mean I think is I think
it's important not to read too much into
it because you're right and we have had
substantial new investment for example
from rolls-royce but that's now we
haven't left yet you start asking people
talking to people about where they think
they'll be in five years ten years time
whereas Toyota are going to look to put
its next model investment and I think
you might find rather a different
picture so are you worried about jobs in
Tahoe very very and what do you think
should happen I've come to the view with
some reluctance because I respect the
fact that we had this consultation but I
have come to the view I take the Prime
Minister's choices what did she say no
deal my deal or no brexit I'm afraid
I've come round to the no exit option I
mean the difficulty is you know I spent
the morning speaking to people in Darby
and overwhelmingly people were saying
that they want MPs to get on with it
they want them to put the party
differences to one side and to sort this
out and actually if I go back to another
referendum you're not sorting out ie or
you're washing your hands there and
saying it's too difficult I think one of
the things that I mean I completely
understand them and totally sympathize
heaven knows it's distorted everybody's
lives mp's most of all but I think one
thing that people haven't always taken
onboard is that if mrs. Mays deal passes
before the end of March that will not be
the end that would just be the end of
the preliminaries if that goes through
if all the legislations passed on
there's a lot of it still to do then the
real negotiations begin that's our
future relationship with the European
Union what our trade deals are not just
with them but elsewhere in the world
including the people we have trade deals
with now as members of the European
Union that will all be in the melting
pot those negotiations will begin when
these are over that your main problem
though is you're not going to get a
second referendum are you there's not
much time left you haven't got the
parliamentary numbness to make it happen
I don't think anybody knows when one of
the things the Prime Minister whatever
her failures the Prime Minister has been
extremely successful at one thing and
that is using the considerable power the
government has to control the agenda of
the House of Commons to make sure that
nobody really gets a chance to express a
view in any context other than had lots
of days we've had endless debate about
endless debates but decision has been
has all been avoided and prevented what
we should have had weeks ago months ago
actually is an opportunity for people to
express preferences between the
different alternatives but she hasn't
wanted that she wants there to be only
one alternative answer and that's the
deal she negotiated if you're not going
to get a second row friend and without
the support with the Labour leader and
he's been pretty enthusiastic as me
Jeremy has followed the pattern of the
conference decision that our party made
which is that we look at the proposals
we put forward proposals of our own we
want to call a general election and then
in the end if none of that is going
anywhere
we don't take off the table the option
second referendum and you say you're not
going to get it quite possibly not but
when you wrote that letter to Teresa may
spelling out his priorities for brexit
he didn't even mention the idea of a
second referendum I mean then we told
that he forgot well that's as bad an
excuse as a dog ate my homework is now
well to be fair the second referendum
option or third actually was not tied in
to the to the alternative deal the this
pattern that the decisions was we look
at the proposals we put forward what we
think would be a better alternative if
we think there is a better alternative
and if that fails then we move on so
that's what he's done has he shown a lot
of need to ship on the brexit I know
that there are a lot of people who would
have liked him to take a stronger stance
and perhaps earlier but the important
thing is where we get you in the end
do you think that the party could
actually split over Breck six it does
feel as if I mean I know the concept of
party is grappling with the same
problems if you look at the labor
benches there are such different views
when it comes to what should happen on
brexit it does feel quite hard to hold
this coalition together well there are
different your different views right
across the House of Commons I mean it's
quite as straightforward as that there
are people I know who have been working
desperately hard people outside the
Labour Party who have been working hard
for years to try to persuade the Labour
Party to split I think it's a big
mistake I would I hope none of my
colleagues take that advice because it's
the worst possible advice they can have
at the most basic and brutal if you want
to change an organization you don't
change it by leaving it what would the
consequences be it wouldn't be good for
them or for the party now you as someone
who has been on the political front line
for 40 years have you ever seen another
time like this
no I and indeed Ken Clark and I have had
this conversation I have never seen such
chaos I have never seen a government
that's so utterly disregarded any
expression of different views other than
the ones they want to hear I've never
seen a government that treated
Parliament with such contempt it's
absolutely unprecedented the Crimean
Prime Minister is tearing up
our Constitution and what do you think
the consequences of that could be I
think they could be very grave I mean if
you have a government that can simply
ignore the biggest defeat in
parliamentary history and carry on as if
it hasn't happened I heard somebody say
the other day that one of the reasons
the Prime Minister is so against having
another vote of the people is because
she doesn't like this thing whereby in
other parts of Europe over the years
sometimes people have gone back and said
you know let's ask the question again
because we didn't like the answer you
gave the first time she's doing that
every day of the week now someone else
who's been in Westminster for several
decades as well as Jeremy Corbyn so when
you've known for a long time has he
changed and those kind of 35 years or so
that you've known him well not until
about the last three or 40 people being
leader of the Labour Party is quite a
life-transforming episode so yes he's
changed you know sort way well he's
grown he's grown into the job I mean
I've heard Ken Clark say that he's
become a perfectly competent leader of
the Opposition and you know when he when
he first took on the post he had had no
experience of the kind of things that
the leader has to do which is a world
away from the activities of an ordinary
backbencher and I think in the beginning
it's fair to say he struggled someone
but he's adjusted massively as he
surprised you yes and now well I've got
you I have to ask you Chacho villain or
hero my father hated Churchill I'm
afraid I know a lot of people I think
it's perfectly right and proper to have
a genuine and sincere respect for the
tremendous role that Churchill played
alongside Ashleigh and others in the
Second World War but I think some of the
hero worship has gone a bit far and I
say that with deep deep respect to
Nicholas Soames who I who I like and who
is naturally very defensive and quite
rightly so about his grandfather but I
think sometimes it goes a bit over the
top why did you why was it that your
father hated Tony Pandey and all the
rest of it
thank you very much